i guess you talked about before how you
felt like you played like a caricature
you know
at which point did you start to like
kind of like not get maybe like not get
tired of it but maybe think like you
should just try to be with yourself more
was there like an exact moment or
realization yeah i think it was like i
think it was a couple of moments i think
at the end of 2017 i have like a video
on my channel saying it was like the
worst year of my life and i was just
miserable i was in like a really crappy
place mentally yeah it was like the
first time i ever got to like the end of
the year and i spent christmas alone and
i was like my mind went to some very
dark places which i won't get into
detail of right but i was like that's
that's not me i don't normally think
like this like clearly something's wrong
and i start like going to therapy and i
start to like figure myself out and my
priorities and then i think like the
next two years after that we're still
trying to like figure [ __ ] out yeah like
i don't know what i want to do do i do
daily uploads again do i work on bigger
things and then kind of getting sick of
myself and yeah i kept taking breaks
so periodically and going away for like
a month or two months and yeah trying to
figure stuff out and then
i think last year after my dad had
passed i was like okay
i'm quitting i'm done i'm [ __ ] out i
hate this yeah i hate where the culture
of youtube is going i hate everything
that's going on i don't want to play
into the games of it yeah and i was like
i just took some time away and i was
like well i don't have to take it that
seriously i started off doing it like
kind of in my bedroom having fun yeah
just uploading daily games and like
subscribers don't really matter that
much if you're having fun with it and
things are sustainable and views don't
matter that much as long as you're still
making like you're living out of it yeah
i've been so successful with it so far
that i'll just have fun with it again
and i think yeah all of those pieces
kind of culminated and i was like that's
it's fun to do
yeah i mean i i think
since we've ordered on youtube for like
quite a long time we forget sometimes
that youtube is a fun job you know
because
there's a lot of times when the grind
can feel endless and you can forget
sometimes that you started it because
it's fun and it is a genuinely fun job
and i feel bad like saying this because
i'm sure a lot of people would like
obviously like kill to be in
in this position but a lot of times when
you hear youtube's talk about their job
it's always in like a negative
connotation uh yeah because it's well it
becomes a thing that when you do it to a
certain level and you get sustainable
and you start earning money off of it
and you get yeah you get to a point
where like your financial side of things
are kind of in check and yeah yeah yeah
you can you can afford rent and food
which is most people struggle and the
friction in their life and then
we we make our own hours all you're left
with are like emotional problems that
you kind of have to deal with right
figure those out and then you have to
figure out your own brain and then
i think for a lot of people it's easy to
blame youtube for like things going
wrong in your life if algorithms shift
and yeah kind of
like go wrong yeah or if an upload does
bad it's like ah [ __ ] the system and
it's like
maybe the video wasn't that good yeah
yeah yeah yeah
people are very quick to blame the the
album yeah there is a factor too of
course it's not all perfect yeah but i
think you know putting all your problems
on the algorithm is something else yeah
it's like an easy out sometimes yeah i
mean i've i've done it too i still kind
of i think we all have that i think
that's like a path that every youtuber
does definitely go through at one point
in their careers it's just a matter of
like whether you can realize that that
is not the entire truth you know yeah
because you put your entire self-worth
into that and when it's successful it's
like i'm amazing i'm doing great yeah
if that dips then it's like i'm a piece
of [ __ ]
oh this works anymore that person
uploaded and it's fine and i do the same
thing yeah yeah yeah and then like
someone new comes on and gets like
[ __ ] 50 million views doing like some
something that you just think is so
simple or something you're like
why is the algorithm favoring this video
and you just like feel like a lost soul
sometimes i imagine that daily uploads
uh make it uh easy to
have
time to think about yourself and where
you are right now
i've never done daily uploads but that
sounds terrifying i think it sucks i
barely already have enough time to
consider my own mental health i feel
like adding in the daily uploads like
where do you
how was that like yeah because how long
did you do daily uploads for like five
and a half years oh my it was it was
double daily did you just have like no
social life during that point oh okay i
was editing everything myself i would
wake up get a video ready for that day
or the two videos ready for that day
then record two more edit them that
night and then go to bed
oh my gosh
i don't do that
it's great when everything's like firing
and like you're getting into it there is
a passion there like sure work hard when
it's there and everything yeah booming
but take some time for yourself yeah so
did you take any breaks at all
seriously i think it was like
seven years before i took my first
proper like time off
oh my god that was circumstantial for
being on tour because i was like i can't
upload yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i tried
vlogging on tour and then i wasn't doing
my tour properly and yeah it was just
too much but that was like the first
time i was like oh people will still be
there if i come back yeah yeah yeah
because i feel like there is definitely
when you set yourself a schedule and
that's how you get like a lot of success
and a lot of traffic initially you think
that you need to stick to this upload
schedule this like uh expectations that
you've set for the viewership and i
think like one thing i will say is i
think youtube's a lot become a lot more
lenient at least recently
uh with just like realizing that your
audience is what really holds the power
and even if you go to like a second
channel they will like your audience
will follow you yeah yeah i definitely
think like nowadays like you know when
like when you were starting off
especially i think the general consensus
was like if you're not uploading daily
then you're not even in the game you
know whereas like now i think the the
the knowledge of
that not necessarily being true and that
as god was saying like your audience
will be there even if you you know
change stuff around or you move stuff
around i think now it's just become more
like commonplace i think where it's like
you know now you have channels that are
starting off who aren't as pressured to
do daily uploads if they don't want it
right like there are lots of successful
channels now that probably upload late
once a month yeah as long as the video
is good i just think the general level
expected of the videos has just gotten
crazy oh yeah yeah that's the thing with
daily as well it's like the daily videos
weren't good yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was just like chopping out bits and
then that's it yeah like heavy editing
on them no because you can't do it like
it's physically impossible to find the
time to do that right unless you're
planning you know weeks ahead but and
they were so much shorter as well like
these days 20 minutes right yeah even i
even it was like 10 15 minutes something
right more manageable yeah like eight
minutes was like the golden zone back in
the day now it's just so weird just
playing a game for like 10 minutes then
be like all right guys
calling it a day yeah i mean that was
like early felix was like amnesia was
like 10 minute episodes yeah yeah yeah
you're turning tomorrow for the next
part yeah it'll take you like a whole
month just to get through like a chunk
of the game because i remember early
game grumps was like that as well like
it was like 10 minutes an episode i was
like all right see you tomorrow yeah
yeah that was normal but now it's like
unthinkable everyone wants like three
hour videos now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it's all it's all like idea first
yeah yeah content after for most of like
the most successful platform like in
that time did you have like a basic
work schedule did you were you just like
okay i'm going to play this game for
this long block out this time to play
game and block out this amount of time
to like edit this kind of segment or was
it just whatever i i don't think i was
conscious of it but i think it just
happened naturally within my day i
didn't even go to my own college
graduation because i was like i need to
edit this video
so i just got my degree mailed to me and
that was
and everyone else went out for like a
graduation party and i was like i guess
i'll go out for a couple of drinks
i have to be home to work though
like nobody else understood it right
right now now it seems kind of silly to
do that yeah yeah enjoy yourself and
have fun but yeah back then there was no
like you can't put your foot in the
break at all yeah yeah yeah there's no
work like ethos yeah he's getting lost
in the shuffle then yeah because i was
doing my first two and a half years of
youtube i was doing daily uploads as
well
while i was a full-time uni student and
the only reason why i stopped doing
daily uploads is because my computer
literally exploded on me
like if my computer never exploded and
like basically just completely stopped
the ability to even like make videos
then i'd probably still be doing it for
as long as maybe you did it yeah even
then it's like i can't imagine you never
missed a day for five years was there
some days you missed i think so i think
there was one day i missed because holy
[ __ ] a tree fell down from a storm and
cut out our power it literally took like
an act of god
my internet was so [ __ ] at home as well
that i would take them to college and
upload them oh my god
i i presume you know during the whole
five years right there was like i don't
know two three years in you were pre
doing pretty well for yourself
yeah so what made you continue when you
had already gotten to a point that was
really successful that you felt that i
need to keep doing this
well part of it was the emotional side
of things where you kind of don't want
to be by yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all you know is the noise and if you're
constantly busy then nothing can creep
up on you yeah yeah yeah sure
and then
you know i think the landscape had kind
of like started to shift and the demand
for i think it was like like life is
strange one came out and felix did like
a whole
like the whole chapter in one video yeah
that was unheard of at the time i was
like you [ __ ] idiot you gave away all
these views
that could have been like four episodes
and then it paid off so well for him and
i was like oh wait watch time is such a
big factor that everyone just started
doing it yeah yeah yeah you just
couldn't do daily really anymore if you
were doing that right right so you
didn't like you did you missed
christmases new years everything ever oh
my god because i was always like well
well i didn't like work on christmas
right right right you you'd walk ahead
if you would walk ahead but it was like
some people are alone at christmas i
want videos for them to go out yeah yeah
yeah i was like i don't want to
disappoint anybody right yeah yeah like
they could they come every day like
after school or after college or
whatever yeah and i guess that pressure
just kept going as the subscriber count
got higher yeah yeah yeah yeah jesus and
then we went to like a a youtube
summit in new york in like 2016 and like
me mark felix like a whole bunch of
casey neistat and a whole bunch of other
people were there
and then
my youtube rep kept like like showing me
around being like this is sean he is
like one of the fastest growing channels
on the whole platform this year
i was like what
like you didn't [ __ ] tell me that
and then i like went up and like susan
wojcicki was there and like my contact
was like this is sean he runs like
jacksepticeye and she was like
uh-huh and i was like okay so what
you're saying doesn't mean [ __ ] right
i was like gassing me up to all these
people and you talked to the ceo of
youtube and had no idea who i was
she did an interview with uh ludwig that
was looked really good yeah yeah yeah
she seemed very chill about it i don't
know i guess she wasn't in tune with the
youtube sphere batman yeah yeah
like just started to get bigger yeah
yeah yeah since then she's been very
very nice to me and she's had a lot of
good things to say yeah she's don't want
to
forget
they say first impressions don't really
matter obviously susan you know it does
okay
she she just got blindsided by me yeah
because she's lovely everybody yeah yeah
yeah
susan for like the ceo of youtube it's
like you think she knows what's going on
the ad department don't even talk to the
marketing department at youtube like no
one [ __ ] knows what's going on
too fast i imagine it when you're at an
event with like every other big youtuber
it's unremarkable if another youtuber
comes right yeah this is another one
yeah it's like you're there at a summit
with like all like some of the biggest
yeah yeah yeah what's another one to you